in the shadow of the mountains of
Afghanistan millions of people are
suffering the consequences of a conflict
which is constantly in the international
media spotlight and if this wasn't bad
enough repeated natural disasters have
only worsened the situation water food
shelter health care all are in short
supply international humanitarian aid
helps the populations but sometimes only
just to survive since 1992 the European
Commission humanitarian aid department
has been assisting vulnerable
populations in Afghanistan by financing
projects in all these sectors
independence neutrality relief which
targets the most vulnerable no matter
who they are their gender political
convictions and religion are irrelevant
these are the values and principles for
the intervention of European
humanitarian aid that Obama killer
bunnies bc i gotta catch'em ago but we
didn't have any access to clean drinking
water before so this hand water pump has
sold all our problems before the NGO
arrived we used to collect water from
the lake which is a long way from here
also the water wasn't very clean and it
made our children sick now we don't have
this problem anymore there's a big
difference between this water and the
lake water pool and as I'm with avocado
Bordeaux we're due for a movie did you
guys hate each other nothing as this
area is it a very mountainous region we
have a very hard life with no access to
any kind of assistance the food day that
we're receiving from this NGO really
helps us out a lot first they surveyed
the area and they found us we were in
need of help then they registered our
names and gave us beneficiary pods the
avery received is really very good and
the distribution is very transparent and
fair go to they must seem doctor quality
of cyril assume they helped us a lot
last year they we settled and sheltered
over a hundred families here in the past
we used to live in tents but now we have
these shelters and it's like a real home
if they could also provide us with the
clinic and schools for our children then
all our problems would be over
verado depois de Guiche cool did the map
tab Julia kidding extra budget
insecurity is seriously affecting
humanitarian operations in the country
in just one year 28 aid workers have
been killed bombs placed on roadsides
are rendering the running of projects
more and more dangerous and in addition
some relief work is being carried out by
military forces and this is blowing the
distinctly separate roles of civil and
military operations the Commission
continues to insist that international
humanitarian law be respected the
situation in Afghanistan is still far
from stable and the humanitarian needs
will remain until long-term development
projects can take effect until then a
cold remain committed to the people of
Afghanistan